син жебраці святу go на форумі у
берліні канцлер смерті ангела меркель
гривні мвф крістин лагард королева
нідерландів максимом міністр козу кордон
exprof канади христе фріланс і данина
президенти США іванка трамп як так
вийшло ще згуртування штати на зустрічі
представляє не перейшов одяганням а
які прийнято називати і сша перша
данька іванка вона німа посадку ряду
проте місяць там про іванку трамп отримала
офіційний статус за потужністю
президенти США про що вона їду цілу годину у
сопромат жувала бачка на офіційних
зустрічах
зараз візиту ангели міркою до
вашингтона монологу місяця
іванка трамп зробити білека сарки не
міченим та татові будинків без нижче
прес-секретар німецького уряду
про подвижники швидкою означав і спиляний
умову сад функціях та федора для багатих
Іванка обличчя білого будинку причому й інша
бліча білого будинку
дональд трамп часто виступаючи агресивно
і що сонце випікаючи негативну оцінку
іванка ж маємо як шипить хіт або point
шуму зловлять білий дим цинку малюється
скоро 100 тис цем судище засіву ви
вирішила їм ерколь вона домагається через
іванка трамп вранці це доступ до
дональда трампа з між охрестила іванку
справжній перший бачимо на відьмину
вигляд мало її капоті ставків дзижчить і в
нью йорку
іванка трамп праці нещодавно переїхала
білий дим на дружина жиру дамку шнуром
і коку називати праву руку і трампом у
подруги троє дітей найменшим узбеки
clash eric h чого ніс ви 35 року в
автора на їх гумкою до праці це
успішний бізнес в обмані у нас заснувала
фірми властивості ювелірних прекрасна ніч
і логіку щось у team і дають за відсотки
банку трампу на форум у берліні
накласти ангелі марки авто поважаєш чим
ерколь знову dieu своєму фірми у must
або прагматичної та політики тисяч line
рубіни президента у porsche а у мене
купіть на посаду
вбив йому будинок з приймаєте на і
lacie виразки чайного так я
німецькому вулику паперові, що новий ти знаю
у мереж не контакти виглядом ще дональд
трамп прислуга йти до думки іванки ви
хвала його жили в їх вирішимо до себе на
пташка вигляд звуку вася просто
ну німецьку економіку можливо найбільшим
часом не кури турків зміниться
схвалили не і каперси данина малюка
стала учасницею політичної дискусії
а з влаштувалася зі злочинцями
німецького бізнесу